uh would you rather throw up anytime  someone says mcdonald's or wear a fedora  wear a fedora for the rest of your life  and if anybody asks you about it you  have to say i like the way it looks that  is  hysterical  and um only two people can wear fedoras  two people uh you know  black people  and justin timberlake  and so like i'm neither of those and so  i can fedora i've never seen someone  pull off a fedora i've been in a  relationship with a girl i'm with puts  on a fedora and i'm like i just have to  be honest you're not pulling it off  you have to wear the hat you can't let  the hat wear you and for the most part  fedoras wear you and so i would throw up  anytime oh someone says mcdonald's i  thought it was anytime i got mcdonald's  no i would still throw up every time i  wear mcdonald's